what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so to be honest with you guys
injustice actually moved a lot faster
than I thought it would and that was one
of the things that really kind of took
me by surprise because you got to work
well whatever we break like a story and
this segments usually takes us like five
six videos or to finish a little thing
with injustice with the first year it
took us two videos for the second year
two videos a third year two videos here
for the exact same thing but year five
is a little bit different and the reason
why I say that is because your five is
where we get down to brass tacks but we
already covered the first part of your
five you know all that kind of good
stuff but I was sitting here thinking
injustice two doesn't come out until
April 11 and even then we still have to
wait for the first story arc to finish
now it may be the first story arc you
know finishes after three weeks in which
case we'll just jump into that first
story arc when it's done but for year
five it's significant in the sense that
this is where we begin to lead into the
video game this is where all the loose
ends are supposed to be getting tied up
this is where all the major significant
and all that suppose the guys who played
the game begin to kind of question and
begin to kind of see things coming to
their full end so what we're going to do
is we're going to sort of pepper out
year five videos a little more a little
more extensively than I intended which
is to say we're going to do a couple
more videos on this really not going to
kind of cram it down into a really short
thing we're going to add a few more
videos you know that I originally
intended but in the last video and I let
you guys on one helmet cliff
I gotta be honest with you whether
you're of course sometimes I just love
leaving you guys on cliffhanger so I'll
go to the comments of seeing your
responses where you're just like what no
you can't just stop there man like I
just I love I love doing that for time
to time it was just kind of a fun way to
sort of mess with you guys a little bit
but any of it we basically have Superman
and bizarro meeting for the very first
time now on the surface this is just
Superman - bizarro fighting right but
there's actually going to be a line that
comes from outfit later on it will be
huge when it comes to this little tidbit
here but all the servers you know like
this dissing me and confrontation
Superman's like what the heck's going on
because remember you know bizarro had
made these scattered appear appearances
here and there but no one knew who he
was
remember bizarre was created by Lex
Luthor as Lazar was basically Lex
Luthor's and little secret Bizarros not
supposed to be out there he just
basically escaped in the midst of a
conclusion of year four and then
elections he's been trying to track him
down ever since so because of this you
know Superman basically comes across
what is for all intents and purposes a
clone of himself
now Superman doesn't know that it's a
clone but Superman has kind of left to
believe that he's the last set of
Krypton
early she's supposed to be the last the
last child of Krypton there should be no
reason why another Kryptonian exists not
only that bizarro looks like Superman so
just by putting two and two together you
know it comes across pretty up being
pretty easily as being a calm but even
then Superman begins a kind of ask the
question are you from another dimension
are you some kind of genetic creation
because at this point there are no
options that are not on the table here I
mean at this point in injustice
Superman's travel to apocalypse each
fought Greek gods Green Lantern Corps
going against the Sinestro Corps to say
nothing of the other cores of the Indigo
tribe and to say nothing of the Red
Lanterns I mean those are all
possibilities that could exist out there
it's just an injustice we haven't seen
them yet we don't even know if they're
real and so what really kind of goes on
here is this idea that in the mind of
Sigma he doesn't know where bizarro came
from he doesn't know why Bizarros here
but when is it happening is they end up
fighting anyway now of course there is a
wise because this just makes good sense
I mean he can't have bizarro in Superman
encounter one another and not fight not
only that remember solomon grundy is
still part of the equation that's one
reason why I left home MacGregor because
all he does is just run off the rhyme of
solomon grundy and it's so cool to see
you born on a Monday you know it's one
of those really really great moments
because it's just one of these things
worse like he's the predecessor to
Marvel's Incredible Hulk you know and
even after Marvel introduced the
Incredible Hulk solomon grundy was
reworked and revamped to somewhat
symbolize would be somewhat similar to
marbles Incredible Hulk it's it's kind
of give and take in the cup of a
community that constantly goes back and
forth which mean all the major
publishers but the idea here is that you
know solomon grundy really the attention
of a votes really bizarro and superman
is given to solomon grundy because
solomon grundy is such a credible threat
you know bizarro is just really more
like a child who's curious about the
situation superman is trying to keep
things contained solomon grundy just
wants to wreck stuff now of course
bringing in house you into the equation
offers a little bit of helping else to
plant fossils because of the constructs
so on and so forth you know but what is
up happening here is the question
everybody has it who is bizarre and when
Hal Jordan makes a comment of bizarro yo
calling him bizarre well the Mazama
basically just kind of takes off he's
like look if you're not going to respect
me you know I'm Superman if you like
respect me but I'm just gonna go home
because remember bizarro kind of has
these weird traits where it's like he
doesn't like to be called you know
bizarro he doesn't like to be made fun
of he doesn't like to be you know talk
down through different things like that
you know as soon as he uh
we abandon the situation leaving
Superman to wonder what in the heck's
going on now from here Superman
incapacitate solomon grundy take solomon
grundy to lex luthor and says to do
something with and do whatever it is
that you did with doomsday brainwash it
whatever you need to do that make him an
asset for the regime but this is when we
start to switch over to what to Damian
Wayne that's what I love about this
because within the realm of the bat
family Alfred is kind of like this
sacred guy you know innocence that
Alfred is the one guy that no matter
what risk is going on and the members of
that family
Alfred is neutral territory Alfred he
looks at Damian Lena says you're the son
of Batman or you're not just some guy
you're not just some character out there
like you are the son of Batman even if
you were like Dick Grayson or even if
you were Jason Todd it wouldn't be the
same yours biological son and he says
you have to mend this rift not only that
but what they're basically talking about
here is we're talking about the idea of
why it is that Damian Wayne has allied
himself with Superman now the reason why
Damian's here in the first place is
because he's having doubts remember the
one day we have to keep in mind with
what's going on in Justice right now is
Damian Wayne is still for all intents
and purposes a kid he's basically a
teenager he's a little bit older but
he's not a man he's not a guy in his 30s
or his forties he's not his oldest
Superman he's out of the oldest Batman
he's still basically a teenager so what
he's essentially going through right now
is everything the teenagers go through
compounded with the current situation I
mean if you're 20 or you're 30 years old
imagine where you were when you were 15
16 17 18 years old trying to figure out
your place in the world trying to
understand what direction you're going
and trying to figure out what you stand
for and what you believe in and then
imagine that now your loyalties are torn
between a man that literally brought
peace to the world versus your father
and then turn around and compound that
with the idea that you yourself don't
even know whether or not you're doing
the right thing that's where Damian
Wayne is that he's being pulled in every
single direction and every single
direction conceivable not only that he
was basically responsible and still
feels he's responsible for the death of
Dick Grayson and so because of this it
has Damian Wayne's mind all over the
place it has him everywhere and this is
really when he's just kind of sitting
down and he's questioning can Superman
win because over he believes it's
Superman's doing the right thing the
goal of that man is always to event
eliminate crime the goal
Batman was always to event bring peace
to the world the difference of the
reason why he made Wayne allied himself
with Superman is because and Damian
Wayne's mind as a student of the League
of Assassins as somebody who was
basically taught to kill to eliminate
threats by any means necessary but then
turn around and and you know only to
meet Batman tomorrow let's have the
belief instilled in him not to kill
people well it doesn't make Damian
inherent good guy while he doesn't
wholeheartedly believe in his father
he's more like Superman than he is like
Batman Damian Wayne's ideology is to
follow Batman's lead to eliminate crime
but he's also willing to follow
Superman's lead to kill those who would
commit crimes and that's what's
interesting is because it creates this
crazy situation you know if for example
I were to tell you that whenever a
person commits a crime they should just
be executed for that crime and no
questions are asked well the people will
say well that doesn't deter people from
committing crimes yet so we're not
trying to deter them from committing
crimes we're trying to eliminate repeat
offenders a person can't go back out and
rob a bank what's the release from jail
if they were never put in jail and they
were killed instead and so it traits
like these really wild philosophies and
situations but then again what it does
is it puts you in a circumstance where
you basically lose your humanity because
ever instead of saying look everybody
deserves a second chance you're just
like men I really hope you didn't run a
red light because if you did it's
curtains it's drapes you're on the
chopping block and your family's never
going to see or hear from you again and
so it increases really wild situations
and that's why Damian Wayne is so torn
that's why you still hold but in the end
Alfred basically says look Superman
can't win and when Damian says why
Alfred says because Batman has
experienced heinous things but in the
end Batman has come out on top because
he's smarter because he's a fearless man
Superman's life is mired by fear and
that is the inherent difference between
the two that's that was that's the whole
basis of injustice that's the point of
the injustice story in relation to
Superman people look at Superman and
they say man yo is this guy who's just
like this pillar of greatness who stands
for everything done Superman is a guy
who is afraid that because he lost Lois
Lane that he's going to lose everything
else
Superman is essentially become so
extreme and becomes so dangerous because
he's afraid he'll lose Wonder Woman
because he's afraid he'll lose Hal
Jordan bet he'll lose Damian Wayne that
he'll lose Batman that he'll lose his
friend there's a reason why he's not
killing Batman there's a reason why he
wants to take that man prisoner if
simply I wanted to kill Batman he to
kill him already we saw the inner thigh
of Superman what he really believes in
his heart of hearts when he had his
dream at halfway through year for it and
so because of this again it creates this
really cool situation because what this
does is this really points to the idea
that maybe it's true that Superman just
can't win
you know Batman can't defeat Superman
but it doesn't mean that Superman can't
be defeated by another means not from
here we actually end up following Damian
Lane when he travels to go see Catwoman
now again at this point keep in mind
Catwoman has basically walked away from
the insurgency she's walked away from
Batman she's out her stuff with Harley
Quinn and Holly Quinn has some measure
of loyalties for Kat water just because
of Gotham City sirens just because of
the time they had together when they
were basically you know kind of a
vigilante group doing their own little
you know film in Louise going crazy a
lot of poison ivy you know having your
own little fun being their own little
group and it worked out well then that's
why they have a lot of loyalties here
even if it's not for that reason is
because Catwoman would just let Harley
Quinn just kind of run amok and do
criminal stuff but the idea here is that
Damian Lane is approaching Catwoman
because she knows Batman better than
anybody else and because she knows
Batman better than anybody else she
could offer Damian Wayne input and one
of the things that I hope you guys know
here is that what Damian Wayne is
basically doing is beating around the
bush and talking to everybody but Batman
he's basically going through and you say
what hey Catwoman you're like that man
in this capacity hey Alfred you're like
that man in this capacity going to these
different people who are you know who
all in some form or fashion represents
what Batman believes and then take all
their advice put it together and say
this is probably what my father would
say and then go forward with that action
he's systematically getting Batman's
opinion without actually talking to
Batman himself and that's why what makes
us so cool is because I would say that
at the end of all this Damian Wayne is
still just ashamed he's still just
ashamed of the fact that he feels like
he killed Dick Grayson which he did he
hit him in the head with a baton Dick
Grayson fell down and his neck broke
even dig races you know it said hey look
man you can't hold yourself guilty but
it doesn't matter Damian Wayne still
holds the guilt over himself
and you know when he's talking to
Catwoman again it's just kind of like
this cat mouse thing they're going back
and forth or doing a little bit of
fighting so on and so forth but when it
gets to the point where he begins to let
his guard down this is where things get
ironic because what Catwoman does is she
sort of listens to him for a second then
usually really just used was like kind
of a masive source gasses him and then
takes off but if she hadn't done that if
she had talked to Damian Wayne and she
literally listened to what he had to say
and they just sat down on the rooftop
and they had a heart-to-heart
conversation I would say there's a 90%
chance she could
pull Damien back from where he was and
brought him back over to Batman but
instead she goes on the offensive and
when she does it really just kind of
sends a me and Wayne back into a
defensive mode now remember at this
point in time Damian Wayne is still very
much self-destructive where he is right
now I mean he's really in a dark place
and so it's really a matter of self
punishment you know it is really him
just kind of you know looking at where
he's at and say okay look I have to make
up for past for past him I have to make
up for the things that I've done before
I have to become a better person
I killed a Grayson I stripped bruce
wayne of what he calls his first son
what really is his first hunt because of
that i have to be his person i have to
make him in as it was literally Damian
Wayne saying I have to become Nightwing
and so instead of being reasonable
instead of being rational in his anguish
and his grief and in his anger he makes
a boneheaded decision he literally goes
into where the remainder of Gotham
City's villains are holed out and
attached them all black mask scarecrow
Mad Hatter Tweedledee Tweedledum and
Valeo the whole nine yards all these
guys he goes through and just starts
fighting them off now he could take them
out he tries as best he can and he does
to a degree the problem is that once the
reserves start coming in once bronze
Tiger once all these guys start coming
in well then it's just sheer numbers
then it's overwhelming and this is why I
say the Damian Wayne's motivation for
fighting all these guys is half to fill
the shoes of Dick Grayson I mean that's
just half of what it it he just wants to
feel this use added grace that he wants
to make amends and be Nightwing's
the other half of this is I think he's
praying for his own desk he's hoping
that if he's going to die he's going to
die honorably died in battle and then be
spared his own grief so because of that
he's overwhelmed by the sheer force of
numbers I remember at this point in time
Dick Grayson is basically dead mad
that's what we saw when it came to like
you know two years three your fourth you
know the whole idea of magic and so on
and so forth it was this idea that Dick
Grayson spirit was basically resurrected
from the dead Eddie now has the ability
to just travel around the world as a
ghost and take possession of people's
bodies and that's what he does he takes
possession of the body of Ron's Tiger
you know of course the martial arts
criminal and he literally just subdues
everybody I mean he takes everybody out
now the reason why did Grayson was able
to do this and the body of Rod Steiger
where Damian Wayne wasn't is because for
Damian Wayne does have a lot more
training with Dick Grayson where I think
he is the better fighter
all these villains will look at Ron's
talking like what are you doing man
you're on our side that momentary second
of guessing that moment
not really knowing what's going on gives
Dick Grayson the opportunity to really
subvert them all and to take pretty much
all of them out and so what this does is
this transitions over to cyborgs and
when does them happening is this
basically a gift that's been left behind
for Damian Wayne while he was
unconscious while he was recovering when
his body was dropped off by Grayson
scalar disguise has brought tiger and
then took off before anybody knew what
was going on the president turned out to
be the costume of Nightwing and so in
the game this is how Damian Wayne gained
the costume of Nightwing you know
there's a message from Dick Grayson is
dropped off that basically says you know
do you really need an invitation become
nightly carry on the legacy that I
started keep the mantle going and so
it's not like Damian Wayne stole the
mantle of Nightwing for himself Dick
Grayson
gave it to him he said become Nightwing
if this is what you need to move on if
this is what you need to become a better
person if this is what you need to
recognize how dangerous Superman is then
take that mantle become that guy and so
what happens of course Superman visits
Nightwing this is actually a really
really great conversation between the
two because what is them happening here
is as they're talking with one another
the question that Superman has is why
would you go and face all those villains
by yourself and Amyas response hero has
to do with hers and so on and so forth
Superman replies by saying hey look
courage is a great thing but courage is
only good because of fear you're only
brave because you know the alternative
is die and this is where we find out
Alfred's right outfit is correct when he
sits down and he says look Superman's
life is mired by fear
he believes that being afraid is a
strength because being afraid means that
he recognizes that he has something that
he that he can lose but being afraid
also means that if you're afraid of
losing those things you'll go to the
ends of the earth to make sure that you
don't lose those things and it's in the
process you end up losing yourself well
then of what was the point what was the
point of the whole journey in the first
place and so fear ultimately it leads to
self-destruction and the attempt to keep
from losing the things you care about
you lose yourself so that's one of these
a Batman oh it's always hard on if you
cannot succumb to fear because if you do
everything you fought for will a will of
God in vain because then at some point
you'll cross a lie that you can't come
back from
and what Damian does is he basically
reiterates these things the two races
lucky dolls are going to offer it offer
said your life is mired by fear fear
governs your life the fear that you'll
lose everything you care about now
you're you experienced when you
accidentally killed Louis and your
unborn child and of course Superman on
my service is like a hooker as you know
I'm really glad you're on the team
it's good to have you back I'm glad
you're okay but in the scowl that he has
we know that's true Superman knows
that's true
Superman's life is mired by fear he
knows that just as well as anybody else
and that's why it's so cool is because
Alfred's right
Alfred's 100% right and that's what
presents one of the most dangerous
things for Superman is because
Superman's regime is powerful only so
long as no one is willing to stand up to
him but if someone like Alfred a butler
with some medical skills and no
abilities is willing to say yeah
Superman's a coward and his life is
mired by fear then Superman's regime is
an absolute because if a regular Butler
would be afraid of them but what does
that say about police what does that say
about armies what does that say about
governors and people of the world well
they wouldn't necessarily rise up
against them now still rise up against
them later and so Alfred presents a
credible threat to Superman in terms of
what he stands for and what it is that
he represents but without being said
guys we're going to bring this video to
an end if you are new here to come in to
explain it make sure you hit the sub
button to become part of the robb Corp
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
all later
peace
[Music]